foreign
[Music]
thanks for being here I get to talk to
you about a package called censored it's
a new tidy models package for survival
models
and when people hear survival analysis
they often think of situations and data
like this
and I mean it's called survival analysis
for a reason but
um
even the most examples are indeed of
like category time to death
uh that is not the only context in which
you might encounter census data and
hence a need for survival models
and um I came across my favorite example
for sensor data before I joined our
studio I was working at a data science
consultancy and one of my colleagues
chatted to me about his latest project
and that involved a newspaper company
which wanted to know how many copies
they should deliver to various outlets
and he was sort of musing that
um if there are any copies left at the
end of the day they wouldn't know how
many had been taken and what the demand
for the paper was
if there were none left they would also
still know how many were taken but they
wouldn't really know what the demand was
and how many more could have would have
been taken if they hadn't run out
so in that case their observation of the
newspaper demand
is actually censored it's capped at the
numbers of papers that they provided
so the stats nerd in me grinned and was
like
I suggest you look at survival analysis
and now I get to tell you basically the
same thing too
so if you have data of this format where
you're observing something until an
event
be that time to death or newspapers
taken until demand situation
um and you may or may not actually
observe that event
please use survival analysis that is
designed to take both of these aspects
into account so if you take that data
and shove it into a regular regression
model
um and modeled a time or the demand
without taking that event indicator into
account you're treating the observations
as complete when in fact they may just
be incomplete
and if you're dropping all of your
centered observations and model the rest
you're also throwing away information
and you're treating these observations
as missing well they are actually just
incomplete
so survival analysis is an important
field of modeling and we're extending
support for it in tidy models
the five the first milestone in this are
the models themselves to be able to
specify them fit them and predict with
them
and you may well be aware that R has an
abundance of riches in different models
contributed by different people
and it also has nearly the same
abundance of riches in interfaces to
these models
and as you just heard tiny models wants
to make it effective safe and ergonomic
for you
and part of that is to provide you with
a consistent interface
and the aspect in tidy models that takes
care of a consistent interface for
models themselves
is parsnip
so it's designed to give you consistency
both in how you specify and fit the
model
and how you predict and what you get
back
um so you don't have to remember
function names argument names across
different packages whether or not you
get a vector back or a matrix or a data
frame
and what that type of prediction was
called in this particular package you're
using
and
the thing I'm really here to talk about
is censored which is a parsnip extension
package so for survival models so I'll
be talking about how these design ideas
play out and Mary with survival analysis
let's get to that first part to specify
and fit models
in parsnip
um you need three elements to specify
your model so for one the model type in
the example here it's a random Forest
and you need a computational engine
that's what you use to fit the model my
example here lets the ranger pack
often that's various R packages it can
also be tools outside of our like stand
if you have a Bayesian model you want to
fit
and the third element to a parsonant
model specification is the mode
a random Forest can be used for
regression or classification so you need
to specify that here
and these three elements
are so very consistent in parsnip so
they will also show up in sensors
so what is actually new is censored well
we have to make a few additions but one
we have a new model type called
proportional hazards
to let you fit everyone's favorite Cox
model
um second of all we have a new mode to
distinguish sensory regression from
regression
and thirdly he probably guessed it
several new engines two existing models
so with that centered covers parametric
models semi-parametric models and tree
based models for survival analysis and
the last point that I want to mention
here is that we have a formula interface
for all of these models most of the
engines do that already the glimnet
package sort of famously does not
but we let you interact with it do a
formula interface and that includes a
way to specify a stratification
and that's all sort of
and I wanted to have a data example
sadly I do not have access to that
newspaper data but I bring you dolphins
and whales
so
um these are dolphins and whales living
in captivity in the U.S whether they've
been captured or rescued or were born in
captivity
it's originally a tidy Tuesday data set
all the way from the pudding
and we have the response age and the
First Column how old is that dolphin
um is or was
if event zero the dolphin or whale is
still alive and we know the species to
sex and how many times this animal was
transferred between different facilities
in the U.S
so if we want to go fit that brand new
model the proportional hazards model and
party models
um we need censored and we need the
proportional hazards function
and then we can add
an engine I'm going to go with the very
classic survival package here as the way
to fit this model
I'm going to add the mode that's the new
sensory regression mode
and with that I have like the
specification this is not fit yet if I
want to apply it to data I have the FED
function
and that's where the formula interface
comes into place your response is
typically a server object
um on the left hand side of the formula
and
you want to add stratification
you can do that like you would do in the
survival package
and at a strata term into the formula
if you're looking at this and saying
well that's a plenty of lines of code
for a model
that is indeed true so if you work with
the survival package directly that's all
a little bit condensed
um just the modeling function the
formula and the data that sort of does
specification and fit all roll into one
and that's great
um we're sort of
sensored comes more into play is if you
want to use something else in addition
to try it out and move between different
models
so if we want to go from sort of the
standard proportional hazards model to a
regularized version of that model
I'm going to move all of the code to the
left and start doing that with the
glimnet package on the right
that one has no formula interface as I
mentioned
so you need to make your response Matrix
a predictor Matrix and the predictor
Matrix
I'm doing that with model Matrix here
and if you want to include
stratification
you need to stratify your response and
then you're ready to go
you put it into glemnat remember to set
the family to box otherwise you're
fitting a different model and give it a
penalty parameter Lambda
so of course this is doable
but the code looks quite different and
it's quite a lot of work to go from one
to another
and we want to make that aspect easier
so obviously the next code is a little
boring
you can take the bit that we already had
first insert
and copy it over and then the main thing
you change
is what engine you sit
one is the survival package one is Gomez
and the other thing you want to change
is penalty parameter because it's gone
there but the rest is the same so we
don't have to fiddle with the data
structure here we can still use the
formula interface
and if you want to switch to yet another
type
the tagline for that is kind of more
models same syntax so you might swap out
your model type for a boosted tree and
set the engine to M boost and you're
ready to go
and that applies sort of to the rest
we have in Centered for that new mode
sensor regression the parametric models
in the survival rag function
proportional hazards or semi-parametric
and then the tree base models are
decision trees random forests bag trees
and boost trees you just
and that's the section on specifying and
fitting
and the next one is obviously predicting
and in the Tidy models framework we give
you a little guarantee that
your predictions will always be inside a
tibble
and the column names and types are
unsurprising and predictable and the
number of rows in new data and the
output are the same
so what's new then
answer is new prediction types one of
them for survival analysis is the
survival time
so I'm just taking the first three rows
here of my data set to predict on them
adding in an A in the first row just to
mix things up a little and you can get a
prediction of the survival Time by using
the predict function and setting type to
time
and you get a table back the column will
always be dot Pride underscore time
and it will have three rows because you
put three rows in
so if you have a missing value it will
have an a rather than miraculously
disappear on you
and um the other big new type for
survival predictions is the survival
probability
um that is always calculated at a point
in time so here in this example I'm
setting type survival
and I want the survival probability at
age 10 15 20 and 40 years
dolphin or whale that I'm looking at
and what do you get back
is still a tibble it has three rows for
the three observations
but we've asked for four time points so
this is actually a list column and it
has little tables stashed inside of it
we want to look at one of them
we can pull it out and then we see
the column that gives us the information
about the time point that we're
predicting on and the probability except
for in this case it's an A but if you
look at the other one you do get actual
probabilities
and um
this does not return you like a
classical serve object surf fit object
if you do want to access the full
survival curve you can pretty easily
um just dial up the number of kind of
points you asked for
so here I'm asking for survival
probability predicted at age one all the
way through 80.
and then I can unnest that thing to sort
of tackle the little tibbles underneath
each other and I'm
squeezing in the mutate to be still able
to tell which rose belong to which
dolphin
and that gives you a data set that is
ready for PG plot
and you can easily do your visualization
of the survival curve with a the
Armstead
so to recap
um
the prediction types that are new are
time for survival time and survival for
survival probability
these are available for all of the
models that aren't censored and
depending on the engine you might also
be able to break the hazard the quantile
of the event time distribution or the
linear predictor if your model has one
you do not have to do any of like the
data prepped for a matrix interface you
don't have to pad your results at the
right place if there's a missing value
in there and you also don't have to do
the lag work to go from a survival curve
to predicted probably at like any given
time point
and
um the summary of the sauce basically
censored is a consistent interface for
survival models it gives you consistency
in how you specified fit and consistency
in how you predict and what you get back
so
please try it out
[Applause]
thank you so much Hannah we have time
for a few questions so I'll take them
from slido again if you have questions
to ask Hannah at slido the event ID is
Inspire ins p-i-r-e uh so we have a few
here do you have any resources or
recommendations for folks who want to
learn about sensored regression in
general
um
so well one
Emily
uh I forgot the last name
Sabor yes thank you zebra metrics is I
think the Twitter handle she has an
introduction that is
um really good I like
um as a blog post
um if you are more on a type that you do
want to die Dave and you want a textbook
um risk regression modeling is probably
good
um I'll tweet those out afterwards
we have some tidy models resources for
the sensor regression stuff
um
not about sort of learning survival
analysis per se
there's examples out
on the
um sensored home page
um the URL is up there
how you can like use all of the models
but it doesn't cover the spirit
step this way
risk regressions
um
down the line probably yes so
um
that is a thing that has been mentioned
several times so it is definitely an
hour radar
uh are there plans to port to support
random Forest Back ends like Ranger
so uh Ranger is
not yet in there but
like one of the two that are sort of
gonna come next of the engines
so there was a question about is
censored able to work with workflow
objects I would expand that further is
censored able to work with tidy models
as an ecosystem in general
um as like all aspects of the ecosystem
not yet I am still having some work to
do
uh you can use it with workflow objects
you just have to not push the formula to
it but rather the variables and specify
the formula as a
um sort of engine argument
um
I'll put a vignette on that
online
uh maybe one more question what is the
difference between stratifying
disappeared what is the difference
between stratifying on a variable in the
survival model and using that variable
as a predict
so stratification
um in a Cox model gives you the idea
that the Baseline Hazard is different
between groups and you like that sort of
the the non-parametric part the Baseline
um and your predictors are the
parametric part that modulate it and if
you think that this Baseline Hazard is
not proportional between groups but for
other fundamentally different then you
would put that in the stratification
all right let's give Hannah another
round of applause
[Applause]